all right welcome back bros we're gonna
start right off with fencing with the
penis all right bring it penis the bleep
big long and black penis and hairy
payments oh man this is my sound really
wrong all right bring it man that's what
I'm talking about all right
let god [ __ ] son is still buy all
right whatever whatever
just bring it bring it bring you left
right bring a penis come on brick penis
penis left no problem hello though side
is so awesome all right why more penis
it's just you and me I'm watching you
penis don't don't look away my not
talking to your penis Wow Adam okay no
prom I can't say I'm just good yeah
hey there's a cops all right it should
be faster now
yeah oops I was recording why whatever I
didn't make a mistake
I love the fail I did in the upload
wrong fight
what stuff with all these background ice
really someone like [ __ ] preparing
for I don't know this this game is
horrible now the phone is recalling like
why do you want for me it's like every
soundings know something I don't know
and I'm just going to turn off the Sun
and just talk about my fail alright
in part I can't do that I can't this
could be it yeah she's your [ __ ] okay
this is it boys and girls
hopefully we can finish this [ __ ]
[ __ ] now use the key buddy Mickey that's
your real name right - up [ __ ] action
higher Oh what the [ __ ]
what's up with that dude
bro-bro are you doing Bob oh no oh this
is not good except Madras mattresses
though sheets and [ __ ] oh god oh god no
all right Carol
girl oh [ __ ] hate this huh girl you dare
girl why can I walk past these too much
for the [ __ ] we engine probably got
AIDS game I should all die I went to
Venus dying when Tina's not even
hospital I think yes what am I supposed
to walk oh I know I know
let's go here no oh wow which game just
game Raj I think this would be my last
part unless little at in the second one
second third one is really good this is
just pissing me off it's too slow it's a
shame maybe I'll just do a plate on my
own and do it like a compilation or
whatever outer gate just over my shelf
it's like kid is here I just hate that
kid thanks so much
okay job Kim oh that I don't trust that
thing it's gonna do something I know it
are you gonna do bra huh of course I
know it I [ __ ] knew it
why did I say he's gonna do something
like now I'm gonna kill myself
Miki's here all right final cambogia
good summary good all right let's see
how these [ __ ] [ __ ] ends girl Wow
mister I've got a stupid cat get out of
here Oh bro no no I'm not gonna fall off
by a [ __ ] gap now now what I don't
hey [ __ ] face me no way no now not on
my watch stupid catty KitKat now make it
you better [ __ ] all down Miggy
ah Nikki just let go of the flashlight
why did why no girl girl don't do it
girl
that's your real name
all right now what come on oh no oh no
oh oh oh that's not good Oh bro lamb bra
now rub rub rub rub rub rub rub rub take
it I don't even know how to shake it by
nigut ba ba ba don't you dare I don't
wanna make out I don't want my got now
oh no no Miki get off me please oh oh
now now uh that was like she's gonna
cool all right
it's not clear yes that one was a
[ __ ] pain in the ass one that emerges
from the heat of one Okin as divided by
violence
scare level whoa damn girl
how's this even possible
all right I got a night I guess
and tomorrow we'll do derelict apartment
I really not sure if we're going to
continue this series or not
we'll see anyway that's pretty much it
bros ah
ah I can't go forward again
alright it's okay nah